Sarah ?
Oui.
Salut.
Ça va ?
Ouais.
Je suis désolé du retard.
Oh t'inquiète, il y a pas de problèmes.
Ok, t'as commandé ?
Oui. Je vais commencer par ton cv...
Super, moi auss... Hein ?
Messieurs-dames, vous avez choisi ?
Oui, je vais prendre le cv du jeune homme, s'il vous plait.
Avec ou sans mensonges ?
Sans.
Cuisson pour les anecdotes ?
Saignante.
Je comprends pas.
T'inquiète pas, tu vas comprendre.
Alors déjà quand on est à un entretien, on se tient droit.
Bah déjà tu peux m'expliquer ce que je fais là...
Tes coudes !
Bien.
Tom, 25 ans, né à Paris, tout ça tout ça...
On s'en fout un peu...
Parcours amoureux ! Ah !
Premier bisou, 12 ans.
Dépucelage, 15, félicitations.
Merci...
Du côté des dernières relations, nous avons...
Sonia, 2 mois. Marie, 3 semaines. Elisa, 1 mois et demi.
Audrey, 2 minutes.
Beaucoup de relations courtes.
Vous êtes un candidat un peu instable...
Disons que j'ai un petit peu de mal à garder un emploi, c'est vrai.
Motif de rupture: infidélité !
Bravo !
Non alors parce qu'on s'emballe vite mais...
C'est vrai que ça a pu arriver que je sois débauché, à quelques reprises...
Moi je vois quand même pas mal de CDD...
Vous avez peur de l'engagement ?
Ah non ! Ah du tout ! Alors moi le CDI c'est quand vous voulez.
C'est vrai que les périodes d'essai se passent pas toujours bien...
Pourquoi ?
Eh bah, conditions d'entretien beaucoup trop élevées...
C'est à dire ?
J'ai pas de thunes.
Votre principal défaut ?
Je dirais perfectionniste.
Menteur.
Ah non !
Si, si c'est marqué là, menteur principal défaut.
Vous avez des passions ?
Euh... Oui...
À part vous branler ?
Moi ?
Sur Youporn.
Je lis des livres...
Eh bien je vous remercie de l'intérêt porté pour le poste proposé...
Malheureusement, après un examen très attentif de votre dossier...
Eh bien, j'ai le regret de vous annoncer que votre candidature n'a pas été retenue !
Eh bien, je me vois dans l'obligation...
Casse-toi !
Oui.
Suivant !
Je vais prendre la tartelette framboise s'il vous plait.